you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme as energy bills for
many are set to rise again we look at
the cost of fossil fuels
versus renewable power the debate over
culling beavers in scotland
campaigners say they improve
biodiversity and flood management
for some farmers they're destroying
precious land
and the sailing competition where teams
race for more than just a win
on the water
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
now the cost of energy for millions of
families will be going up this autumn
after the regulator ofgem announced the
energy price cap will increase
it means bills rising by as much as 139
pounds a year
why well it's mainly to do with the
wholesale cost of fuel specifically
fossil fuels well the cost of gas is
increasing
surging fossil fuel prices are driving
up inflation for consumers
leading to that rise in the price cap
and that matters because we're still
using a significant amount of gas in our
electricity
supply and you can see that's the blue
line here
staying fairly consistent over the last
20 years or so
but great britain's electricity system
is undergoing a period of significant
change as we transition from fossil
fuels to renewables now there's been a
marked increase in wind and solar that's
shown by the green line here
while the use of coal that's the white
line has dropped off
almost entirely so that's the long-term
trend now if we look in more detail at
the first quarter of this year and last
year
we can see that most of our renewable
energy came from
bioenergy offshore and offshore that's
those first three blocks
solar and hydro both account for around
two percent that's the yellow and white
now overall in the first quarter of 2021
renewables provided just over
41 percent of our electricity the third
highest quarterly share on record but
will the move to more renewable energy
actually be any better for consumers
well our correspondent dan whitehead
joins me now so what does this mean for
consumers dan
well initially for consumers this really
will hit their pockets we're down in
devon and we've been speaking to
families right across the county
uh today who from october are braced uh
to
feel the impact of the rise in the
energy cap we've been with the jackson
family
in peyton in devon and they've told us
they are going to have to change
their lifestyle given the amount that
their bill is now going to go up by
so top of the list is obviously got to
pay all the bills
first like gas electric council tax
water bills all that sort of thing
then after that it's all your luxuries
to you know give your family a bit of
fun a bit of entertainment at the end of
the day we like our holidays we like
restaurants
we like going to the cinema um but
obviously
in the back of the mine there's going to
be less money for that now
the advice of course at the minutes is
that consumers can simply switch
to a better deal but the long-term
future in terms of reducing our energy
bills is going to be renewable
and green energy a recent report from
the international renewable energy
agency found that around two-thirds of
the new wind and solar farms that were
built right around the world
just last year are capable of creating
cheaper energy
than the cheapest newest coal plants
that are being created
so we've moved away from knowing that
simply renewable energy is better for
the environment also now it can create
cheaper energy so that will be the
future for people to reduce their bills
but for the time being
across the uk people will simply have to
shop around and switch
they can of course uh select to get an
energy provider that is green that comes
from renewable energy
whether or not that actually is
reflected in how much they pay each
month probably not yet that's going to
be a bit more time
so how do we make that transition from
fossil fuels to renewables
well let's bring in nicholas shaw uk
president of the national grid
welcome to you first of all what are the
cost implications for
individuals of this transition from
fossil fuels to renewables
the good news is we're already well into
the transition we're
way ahead of many countries and in terms
of cost
it's a complicated mixture of the good
news again
is that renewable energy is really free
once we get it once the infrastructure
is there we can then
use the power of the sun and the power
of the wind to generate the electricity
so it's free at the point of uh having
made the infrastructure investment
we paid for the infrastructure over a
long period so
overall we think that it is a really
good investment for um
consumers in the uk and how are we doing
with our infrastructure how much
renewable capacity do we have at the
moment to meet a rise in demand
we're doing really well as i said we're
amongst the leading company countries
in the world particularly in wind um
even we're hitting records in our
delivery
of electricity from offshore wind at the
moment in april we hit
a particular record and we know that
about four and a half million homes in
the uk are already powered by
renewable energy but there is more to do
and we will probably have to double
the amount of electricity we're going to
use by 2050 just because we'll have more
things that are connected to electricity
which means quite a lot more investment
and particularly in the next decade
really want to see a big step
change in the amount of offshore wind
generated electricity coming
onshore and it's interesting you talked
about the next decade because the prime
minister has made a pledge hasn't he
that
every home can be powered by wind power
within that time
frame is that really possible so
a big pledge isn't number one pledge in
his ten point plan the government's ten
point plan
was to deliver 40 gigawatts of offshore
wind by
2030 and at the moment we have just over
10 gigawatts so you can see a big step
up um
and that is feasible but we've got to
get going and there's a lot to do
so you first have to get planning
permission uh you have to then get the
financing in place
and then you have to do the construction
nicholas shaw thanks very much indeed
and don't forget you can see a more
detailed breakdown of the real-time
power mix in great britain anytime you
like on our website skynews.comclimit
wildfires are continuing to burn in
parts of the united states with a newly
ignited fire destroying at least
50 homes in northern california the
river fire which started on wednesday
has charred over 2 400 acres in nevada
and placer counties
authorities are warning the california
could be on track to suffer the worst
fire season
on record well that comes as new
pictures show the extent of devastation
in the gold rush town of greenville
the dixie fire which has burned for
three weeks now
destroyed 75 percent of the historic
californian
town among the damaged buildings were
saloons
the town museum and over a hundred homes
and in greece thousands of people have
been forced to leave their homes in
athens
after strong winds caused wildfires
there to spread rapidly
the fires have been worsened by a heat
dome a high pressure bubble trapping
heat within an area
it's seen parts of the country reach 47
degrees
and meteorologists warn climate change
will make these extreme weather events
more frequent in today's other climate
news cop 26 president alok sharma has
been accused of hypocrisy
after it was revealed he's flown to 30
countries in just
seven months the government says
face-to-face meetings are key
to successful negotiations at the
climate change conference being held in
glasgow later this year
but green party peer jenny jones
criticized the flights as excessive
saying the minister should have used
trains for some trips instead
france's highest court has fined the
government there 8.4 million
pounds for failing to improve air
quality
four years ago ministers were ordered to
reduce levels of nitrogen dioxide
in line with european standards but the
court ruled
insufficient measures have been taken
the court has threatened to issue a
similar fine every six months until
air pollution targets are met
and wine production in france could
slump by as much as 30 percent this year
its lowest level in decades
extreme weather made worse by climate
change meant vineyards were hit by
severe spring frosts and torrential
rainfall
champagne production will also be cut by
around half
after harvests were destroyed by mildew
fungus caused by the fluctuating weather
scotland's highest civil court is due to
issue a ruling soon on the right to kill
beavers rewilding charity trees for life
brought a case against nature scott for
allowing farmers to kill the wild
creatures
arguing control licences are being
issued too freely
the charity says beavers are vital to
improving biodiversity and boosting
natural flood management but for farmers
they can seriously damage
land as guys james matthews reports
beavers are being shot in parts of
scotland where they were released
without authorization
and where they disturb prime
agricultural land
i feel extremely frustrated louise
ramsey has them on her land
licenses to kill she says are issued too
readily
when they build their dams they bury
tons and tons of waterlogged wood
all of this is sequestering carbon the
the other thing is that climate change
as we know causes droughts and floods
beavers hold the water table steady
through both drug routes and floods
holding onto the water on the land in a
time of flood is really critical for
everybody and everything for all these
creatures and for humans
but for the dam builder there's a dam
buster
the people who shoot the beavers are
typically farmers and landowners
they're recognised as being a
biodiversity benefit and in some areas
that's absolutely the case there's no
doubt about that
however whether causing serious
agricultural damage
we need to be able to control them the
scottish government agency nature
scott insists it only issues licences to
kill
if it's satisfied it's the only option
campaigners disagree
and say that alternatives aren't fully
considered
they hope that if a judge agrees with
them fewer beavers will be shot
and more will be relocated from parts of
the country where they're not welcome
to parts where they are james matthews
sky news
perthshire now with all the excitement
of the olympics there's lots of focus on
how to make sport
more sustainable one event already
trying to do their bit is sail
gp teams in the international sailing
competition
don't only race in the water but on
sustainability
too the impact league runs alongside
the racing leaderboard with teams
rewarded for the actions they take
to reduce their overall carbon footprint
and we asked none other than great
britain's sailing legend sir ben ainslie
to explain more
[Music]
the impact league is it's it's really a
race for the teams
we race on the water for the trophy if
you like
but we're also racing for the impact
[Music]
you know we're all competitive animals
out there racing you know to try and win
on the water but
now we're we're racing to try and save
the planet
to try and save our oceans
we take it seriously we take it really
seriously you know the teams are already
they're out there monitoring what each
other are doing in terms of the
the sustainability approach
[Music]
you know we're going to need to see that
level of change
across all sports and across all society
if we're going to meet the targets that
we need to
to get on top of this global issue
we're pushing seriously hard from within
our own sport and within sales gp
and we expect the same from other sports
[Music]
well that's everything from us for today
but don't forget to check out the weekly
climate show
to find out more about the devastating
wildfires in turkey and what calls them
and you can find that on the sky
news snapchat channel and in this week's
episode of climatecast can video games
encourage us
to go green that's out wherever you
normally get your podcast from now
thanks for watching see you next week
[Music]